&gt;&gt; Let's get back to renting cars. This time you want to rent a car, and you're
comparing the cost between two companies, Car-nival and Rent-a-Car. Car-nival's
the same as before. They're going to charge $10 for a registration fee and $10
per hour for renting the car. Rent-a-car is a little bit different. They're
going to charge $30 for a registration fee and $6 per hour for renting the car.
So, which company's the better deal? Is it Car-nival, Rent-a-Car, does it
depend, do they cost the same, or would you rather teleport? This is one of
those questions you really want to take your time on. Try to create a table of
values for Car-nival and Rent-a-Car. You can let x be the number of hours and y
be the cost of the rental car. You can use the table to investigate this or even
create a graph. Try your best.